Anyone who wants to understand
Vladimir Putin needs to know the
story of what happened to him one
night in East Germany 33 years ago.
It was December 5, 1989, just a few
weeks after the Berlin Wall fell.
In East Germany, communism was dead,
although free democratic elections
weren’t scheduled until the spring.
In the east German city of Dresden, protestors
stormed the regional headquarters of the East
German secret police, the Stasi,
completely overrunning the office.
Then, a small group of protestors - reportedly
no more than 20 - decided to head across the
street to the local headquarters of
the Soviet secret service, the KGB.
Russian media later mythologized the incident and
exaggerated the number of demonstrators to 5,000
Putin anticipated the protestors’
arrival and called for help from the
Soviet military stationed in East
Germany to protect the employees
in the office as well as the files
they had on informants and agents.
They tried to burn as many of the files
as possible and even broke the furnace!
But the Red Army was not coming to their rescue.
In his biography, First Person, Putin
recalled being told on the phone:
"We cannot do anything without orders
from Moscow. And Moscow is silent.”
Those words, “Moscow is silent”,
stayed with him because it finally dawned on him
that the Soviet Union had all but disappeared.
Now it was up to Putin to figure
out how to get himself and his KGB
colleagues out of that dangerous mess.
How could he stop the crowd
from swarming the building?
In an interview with the BBC, one of
the protestors, Siegfried Dannath,
recalled how when the mob approached the KGB
house, the guard immediately rushed inside.
Shortly afterward, “an officer
emerged - quite small, agitated”.
That officer was 37-year-old KGB
Lieutenant Colonel Vladimir Putin.
Except he didn’t say he was a spy.
Putin said he was a translator.
He told the crowd in fluent German that
the property was on Soviet territory.
According to the protestor, Putin
told the group to leave, quote:
“Don’t try to force your way into
this property. My comrades are armed,
and they’re authorized to use
their weapons in an emergency.”
Putin was bluffing.
But the mob believed him and backed away.
Leaving staff and the sensitive files unscathed.
Long before Vladimir Putin became president
of Russia, he fulfilled his teenage wish of
becoming a KGB agent - inspired by the
books he read and films he watched.
He spent five years stationed in the isolated
East German city of Dresden, from 1985 to 1989.
East Germany was important to Moscow. It
was a satellite state of the Soviet Union
that sat on the doorstep of NATO,
the western military alliance.
We don’t have much information
about what kind of work Putin did
in Dresden. He’s said little
about his work in the eighties.
Other than speaking about
that December day in 1989.
What he witnessed was humiliating.
He saw the west winning the Cold War as
the Eastern bloc crumbled under his feet.
The Atlantic wrote, “Putin's experience
in Dresden undoubtedly reinforced his
view of his identity and role as the critical
outsider learning from the mistakes of others.”
Soviet leader Mikhail Gorbachev failed to prevent
the subsequent collapse of
the Soviet Union in 1991.
One of the largest and most powerful empires in
history unraveled, breaking up into 15 nations,
leaving Russia a shadow of its former self.
Putin called it “the greatest geopolitical
catastrophe of the twentieth century.”
He later claimed he knew
the collapse was inevitable,
“I understood that a position based on walls and
water barriers cannot exist forever. But I wanted
something different to rise in its place. And
nothing different was proposed. That's what hurt."
Putin never rose to the top ranks of
the KGB, he remained a mid-level agent,
on the periphery. In the nineties, he left the
KGB to become deputy mayor of St. Petersburg, and
by the late nineties, he transferred to Moscow to
work in President Boris Yeltsin's administration.
He was picked to lead the new Federal
Security Service which replaced the KGB.
And then he was surprisingly chosen
by Yeltsin as prime minister in 1999.
He saw how weak Russia had become.
When President Bill Clinton approved airstrikes
against Serbian forces in Bosnia - Washington
didn’t even consult Yeltsin. The Serbs share
deep ethnic and religious ties with Russia.
Putin’s leadership would be very different from
Yeltsin’s when he took over as President in 2000.
He impressed Clinton’s point man on Russia,
Strobe Talbott, the US Deputy Secretary of State,
who wrote in his memoirs that he
was struck by Putin’s “ability to
convey self-control and confidence
in a low-key, soft-spoken manner”.
Putin’s image though is anything but low-key.
He’s frequently photographed
doing super manly things,
like fishing shirtless, overpowering
opponents in judo, or driving race cars.
The macho President has put his tough image on
display for both his fellow countrymen and the
world - reinforcing the image of a strong leader
trying to build up a strong, resurgent country.
In 1999, just before taking office, Putin
stressed the importance of strengthening
the state, writing in an article in the
Russian newspaper Nezavisimaya Gazeta:
“Russia is in the midst of one of the most
difficult periods in its history. For the first
time in the past 200-300 years, it is facing
a real threat of sliding to the second, and
possibly even third, echelon of world states. We
are running out of time for removing this threat.”
Many believe his actions over the years
have been guided by one principle:
to “make Russia great again”
When Russia annexed the Crimean Peninsula
from Ukraine in 2014 - it led to a
spike in Putin’s popularity at home.
And late on February 23rd, 2022, Russia
started attacking targets all over Ukraine.
Why? The clearest answer came from Putin himself.
Two days prior to the attack, Putin
delivered a speech where he described
Ukraine as an illegitimate country, that
it sits on “historically…Russian land”.
He views Ukraine as a lost part of Russia itself.
But Ukraine doesn’t see it that way.
It voted overwhelmingly to
establish an independent state
and now seeks to join NATO which
Putin is determined to block.
Putin’s closest aides today consist of those from
his KGB days or who have security backgrounds.
They are believed to tell him
only what he wants to hear.
He Putin is said to want to rebuild a sphere
of influence in Eastern Europe, bemoaning
the collapse of the communist order which
traumatized him as a young agent in East Germany.
In this latest attack on Ukraine, a Russian
tank could be seen flying the Soviet flag.
Officially, Russia has dismissed the
possibility of reviving the Soviet Union.
Putting this story together from start to finish
in just a couple of days was not easy to pull off.
It’s really important for me to stay
as healthy as possible so I feel good
and can be as productive as possible.
My sponsor BiOptimizers’ mineral-rich supplement
Magnesium Breakthrough aims to help you
beat stress, fatigue, and sleep better.
I have trouble sleeping myself.
And for the past few months,
I’ve been taking Magnesium Breakthrough, and
I’ve noticed my sleep has gotten a lot better.
Most magnesium supplements fail because
they’re synthetic or use preservatives.
When you get all seven
critical forms of magnesium,
your body gets a serious upgrade so you
can feel better throughout your day.
To find out more, go to:
magnesiumbreakthrough.com/newsthink
to get a 10% discount. Be sure to use
the promo code: Newsthink10 at checkout.
You can click my custom link in
the description or pinned comment
and try the powerful effects
of magnesium for yourself!
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom